two they said
we would never show our faces again
yet here we are to prove them all wrong
the h3 podcast
will never die
today's episode is sponsored by
stamps.com
and i'm happy to announce memberships
members only are investing
in the future of the h3 podcast and we
invite you to take our hand on this
beautiful journey
what is memberships you may notice a
little join button
on the uh h3 podcast page
what that does for you 4.99 a month
you get early access to all videos one
day early we upload the same day we
record
that also means that a lot of the
obscenities maybe
content that is too hot for tv
uh stuff that may either get us to
monetize or get us claimed
this kind of stuff we don't have to
worry about on the members only
early access so you get all that okay
one day early
the other thing you get for that no ads
youtube ads
off sponsor reads off it's just me
ela and all the gang and you
raw main line right into your vein boy
the rawest of the raw
raw as a dirty bronze dirty bradberry
and and most and really most importantly
and the reason why we're doing this is
that
uh you can support uh support the show
you know
uh during these times with coved and
everything going on
our sponsors have become frankly less
frequent and
and more inconsistent and our videos are
getting claimed like or not claimed
they're getting uh
they're monetizing demonetized like
crazy like way more than usual like our
last
six videos four of them were demonetized
that's crazy one of them had no ads and
was demonetized so we're kind of in
we're in a pickle we're yeah so we
thought you know would be fun to make
this
kind of membership actually worthwhile
for our fans try to give some kind of
benefit and value there
and also to give you guys the
opportunity to directly support the show
because our hope
is to grow the show i don't want to
scale back i don't want to
worry about that kind of thing i want to
be able to spend 3 500
on a gatsby if we need to if it's what
if it benefits the show you know why not
i think it benefited us
wait till you see we got down the pipe
but wait do you guys see what we wasted
money on next
oh that's true i don't want to say it
too much when did we get that damn
wasted a lot of money
yeah this one is this one makes the
gatsby look like that
yeah um i think it could be as soon
as a couple weeks from now but i don't
want to wow i mean this one
dude this one i don't want to ruin it
obviously but this one has been in the
works for a while
yeah it is epic and we wasted a lot of
money on it
and i think it's gonna be totally worth
it now you may be saying to yourself why
would i support the show if you guys are
just wasting money on crap like the
gatsby
that's a fair question i guess well i
have an answer for you
um you don't have to because for the
non-members
nothing changes true nothing so changes
i know this sounds like a scam because
it sounds way too good to be true
but nothing changes that's true nothing
changes the episodes go up at the same
exact time
they are the same as that content is the
same exact everything
but for those who want to support us
directly and support the show and keep
the h3 podcast
great as it's always been sometimes less
great than others and sometimes
more great than others but we strive for
a pretty
baseline like pretty good but we want to
go more towards the
great if you want to support us hit that
join button
and help support the show we also want
to start doing more episodes
right now we're doing two i want to
start doing three i want to start
eventually maybe by next year doing five
episodes a week yes you heard that right
h3 podcast is coming at you hard
and fast this week we are doing three
episodes
stepping it up so um this week's
episodes are a little bit on the short
side today's episode just because we're
doing another episode tomorrow
so that's why but we're gonna have more
content for you this week
um and i'm very excited about it
actually uh tomorrow
we're having jt and chad
chad goes deep the party bros these guys
are absolute legends
i'm super excited to have them on the
podcast i think they should be a
terrific guess
and i also want to explain you may be
confused because there's different tiers
it says fupatrupa
papa blessed and a true and absolute
legend let me describe what the
difference is
fupatrupa gets you all the benefits at
five dollars a month
and the other ones do nothing you just
give us more money that's how it works
there's literally no difference between
them
uh there you have it so anyway i feel
like i've talked about that enough
let's move on to the to the greatest
show
um in uh our zip code
wow you're really um the greatest
uh show on our uh one-way street
i like that uh so you know
this video was circulating on the
socials there was a mega party in
beverly hills
and these new local news copters went
and cruised over the party and were
filming it like they do traffic
like they're spying on them which is
kind of bizarre kind of
but like i guess the point is like yo
there's no social distancing
there's no uh
there's no masks i mean what's going on
and so okay
here they are it looks like a wild-ass
party people are throwing bills from the
where do you see that here look there's
money falling here let me go back
look somebody's from here is throwing
money on the floor like what the hell
kind of party is this
dan should i get rid of this box can you
see this yeah i just
noticed it was there bye-bye
okay
so these helicopters are just spying on
the party
it's kind of funny kind of weird kind of
funny kind of wild
uh they weren't the only ones there were
several of them
and so i guess they were tagging the
mirror and saying hey go
go break up this party they're they're
not social distancing
league crest tonight where the lapd has
what we're seeing here from sky night
appears to be dozens and dozens of
people
at this party we're told there's a food
truck there as well as a dj
this is a food truck as well as a dj
it's located at this address it looks
like a lot of fun
distancing going on you see the police
officers there we understand
this is a gated mansion just off of
mulholland drive
lapd on the street outside of the gate
we'll continue to follow the story and
find out if they're handing out any
citations
looks like they're having fun so well
they're genius cut so okay like it kind
of turned into a wacky story
turned to a tragic story um
this footage that the la news people
were
broadcasting on live tv
uh well here before i get into that this
was also the kind of things with
circular
circulating around social media so maybe
it's not entirely their fault
right here at hollywood hills uh party
yeah check out
all the women all the rolls royces and
[ __ ] pretty cool
the
he's in the driveway showing off all
these like rolls-royces and
horses and stuff lots of money there
clearly
so anyway i guess a combination of
factors never being invited to a party
like that
i've been to a notch party which is kind
of well the thing is not just usually
the only
rich person there yeah and it's just a
bunch of like
social climbers instagram models yeah
what is a notch party oh literally notch
the guy who made minecraft
debaucherous parties at his 80 million
dollar house
it's like the most deprived [ __ ] you've
ever seen it's so bizarre
because you you expect like a bunch of
nerds playing dungeon dragons just like
maybe maybe not maybe that's a little
stereotypical but like more of a low-key
kind of fun vibe
i went there with um some friends
and it's just so debaucherous it's like
all these it's it's like the
stereotypical
toxic la party with like social climbers
instagram models all these dudes in like
versace everyone spends all day at the
gym
but also it's just weird like no one
knows each other it's just
nobody knows people just show up and
notch himself wasn't even really hanging
out there it's just kind of i don't know
why he does it
i'm just so perplexed by by why does he
do that because he's not sure
i mean i'm assuming he probably just
wants to [ __ ] that could be the only
conceivable reason is that he just wants
to [ __ ] some cuties
that's a lot of effort for right and and
yeah i mean hey
it's impressive right so what's the
craziest [ __ ] you've seen there well i
actually didn't stay around long but
it's just lots of lots of illicit drugs
lots of drinking
that's why we had the logan paul story
yeah
i tell that again no no i'm kidding
make fun of me because i apparently tell
that story a lot how dare they make fun
of me first of all it's a great story
it is a fantastic story thank you zach
um
anyway it's just it wasn't my vibe
obviously and then it's like anyone who
recognizes you is like
dude hey i've got uh what's up man and
they like i work for
i do this i work for this uh youtube
it's always like i work for this youtube
mcn
something like that you know
[Music]
and um yeah you could tell that none of
these people
even know what minecraft is you know
and then when notch cruised out he was i
saw him briefly he was like wearing a
fedora
and sandals and like you know
he's totally like sticks out like a thor
a sore thumb
he's really the great gatsby i mean
there's really no way to describe it
uh anyway that's neither here nor there
gatsby
what is that the great big gatsby
the great big isn't he a big guy oh you
just called him
what are you making fat jokes yes i was
making a little bit of a fact yeah he's
husky he's husky
we don't call him fat that's just rude i
just called him big
healthy well he's healthy
no he's he's he's in he's
apparently i i actually liked notch and
i was i was
apparently i said something to him at
that party which he's never forgiven me
for
something about yeah i don't know i
don't even remember what i said but he
like
i i said something to him in past i was
actually excited to see him because i
had never met him and uh we had talked
on twitter and the dm's before and i was
i wanted to hang out with him you know i
didn't care about all these other people
there
and i said man this i said why you par
something about partying a lot i think i
was just goofing around but apparently
it hit him hard
and uh he like i talked to him
briefly like a month ago and he
met brought it up like that i wounded
him with my comment
really yes yeah i remember that on
twitter he got all pissy
at you yeah he started he got real like
this was all public by the way i'm not
like revealing anything uh
private he was he was being like real
busy to me on twitter it's weird man
i gotta dig up that he's notoriously
an [ __ ] i don't i mean he was nice to
me
and
yeah he was being kind of rude to me i
thought too yeah
but then he's like oh yeah well you said
this mean thing to me like three years
ago about
partying too much i was like ugh i don't
i swear i don't remember saying that but
i'm sorry
i was i i only remember what i felt was
which was that i was excited to meet him
and talk to him and hang out with him so
but i am i can be an [ __ ] i mean i
certainly don't
uh deny that
right who doesn't
here's his tweet actually i don't feel
very comfortable interacting with you
because i'm still bummed you told me i
party too hard after i invited you over
to a party
you were correct by the way the only
interaction we have
is you inviting me onto your podcast i
find it cringy
oh right oh yeah so he goes so by the
way
notch tweeted out something like nobody
wants me on their podcasts anymore
and i was like you i was like you're
welcome to come on our podcast
i'd love to have you and then he goes
dude all you ever do is want to invite
me on your podcast it's cringy i was
like what
you baited me into inviting you
and he's he's yeah i mean what dan read
speaks for itself i was like
all right dude yeah really cross the
line
can you find the original thing he was
like
yeah very fascinating the non-stop
barrage of requests for me to stream or
go on podcast or host things completely
stopped
right and this was because he's like a
total like alt-right
[ __ ] now and you say come on i don't
i don't want to make any no i don't
endure i mean that dance said
but that is why everybody stopped asking
him to go well he got political
yeah and so a lot of people didn't want
to
be to associate with with political
stuff
and so i said well well hang on i'd love
to have you on the podcast
and then he called me cringy
yeah and by the way tweets
what i'm just looking at some of notch's
deleted tweets he says like global
warming is a hoax
if we're allowed to discuss iq
differences between populations there
would be fewer conspiracy theories yeah
yeah it's like a giant [ __ ] i will
stand by that we should make it illegal
to use the wrong
pronouns he says [ __ ] like that so wow
so obviously you can understand a lot of
people not wanting to associate with
that but i'm like dude
i'll i'd love to chat with you and by
the way his claim that
the only time we've associated is me
begging him on the podcast
is absolutely false i used to hang out
when i was with justin roy then we used
to be like let's
hang out with notch all the time we
would call him we and me personally but
without justin i would reach out and say
hey let's hang out because i was like
here's a guy who's surrounded by people
that always want something
i don't want anything from i just want
to hang out and every time i i would
reach out it was just like a hard no
same thing when we were with justin i
think uh
basically maybe i have a vague memory
that one of those times when you
just wanted to hang out he basically
invited you to a party but you're like
you're
not into that stuff he invited us to
come to the party
i went to the party he only cruised
through
like uh very briefly and that's when i
made apparently this
apocalyptic comment about him partying
too much which by the way doesn't sound
that rude even when he
retells it i mean and then he says
you're right
he does have this crazy parties like
every friday he should
at least be self-aware of what he's
doing he's known i mean people
know him in la in the partying scene as
the crazy beverly hills party guy
yeah so it doesn't seem like much of a
stretch
to comment on no it's it's true well he
said it's true
uh so i think if anything i was just
like yo dude let's let's hang out i
don't i don't i think you know what i
mean like
let's let's hang out probably just a
lower iq
you think i'm a lower iq actually all
these people who believe in like iq and
populations generally give
uh the actually you're lower iq yeah i'm
higher
i rubbed it off on you so oh [ __ ] we're
both just low iq
it's so funny when you listen to these
people they say apparently when
when these like uh iq raiders by
they they give that the uh uh
see look look at my iq level working
right now
at the highest iq of any population
i'm here to prove that single-handedly
wrong
so i smashed
[Laughter]
your dns test we found out you were uh
like 99.9
yeah one billion percent so that
pure chosen person
does it sound like chosen person
acid reflux clear throat i'm trying it's
like
never ending like i go then
anyway we were totally on a tangent big
time tangent
the point is i feel like i should just
move past the story i guess people want
to know what happened
anyway the point is going back to the
mega health party in beverly hills
because the local news was covering it
with these helicopters
gangsters showed up robbed everybody and
shot a bunch of people
so crazy twist
yeah we were tracking this story last
night and then i woke up
and opened twitter at like 8 a.m and the
first thing on my feed was like shooting
at that party i was like oh my god that
took it well i was like
could that be the same party and it was
sure enough
but yeah i mean everyone's like look at
all these wealthy
people they've got djs and food trucks
and rolls royce
and there appears to be money being
thrown off the balcony
here's the address here's the uh
passcode right i don't understand this
the news
coverage here a lot of times when it
comes to like uh
car chasers they'll follow the chase
like it's an
action movie yeah get some good ratings
and
it's like a huge thing it just feels so
wrong i think they do it elsewhere too
but
la in particular for whatever reason
reasons with the car chase yeah
you got the freeways you got the uh but
it's it's um i just feel like it's
encouraging it oh it's horrible i mean
it's just horrible people should not
watch that
you know when i was a kid i loved it
because there was
you it was alive right so it's kind of
hard not to watch
because like their responsibility should
be on them not to
air that of course and you know the the
allure is like because it's live
what's gonna happen when i was a kid
people there was a dude who like shot
his brains out on live tv i remember
that one
and there's just like gnarly crashes i
mean it should not be until that was the
one because of that one
now when they like are coming to a
conclusion they always zoom way out
because they got a lot of flack
because yeah they've got a lot of flack
yeah yeah they've been well because they
broadcast that dude blowing his brains
out on live television
like maybe we should zoom in on this
they probably just shouldn't do it at
all
anyway that is that so uh
so i guess i don't know congratulations
to everybody involved
to the non-social discipline party to
the local news
um and condolences to the people who
were
shot and a shout out to notch as well
while we're at it
we're gonna throw to a break quick
there's only one ad but when we come
back
i am taking i'm going to war with
impulsive the podcast
that's it the gauntlet's been thrown the
line in the sand's been drawn
that's it all at war when you come back
shots fired
as we slowly adjust to new normal
we need to be smart about how we do
business luckily elon
there's stamps dot com to make things
easier
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits
of stamps.com in recent months they've
been able to keep their businesses
running and avoid the crowds at the post
office all
from their computer folks with
stamps.com you can print postage on
demand
and avoid going to the post office and
you'll save money with discounted rates
you can't even
get at the post office stamps.com also
offers ups services with discounts
of up to 62 percent and no
residential surcharges pounded on that
you know what they're talking about
sams.com brings all of the mailing and
shipping services you need right to your
computer
and the comfort of your home or office
whether you're a small business sending
invoices
or an online seller shipping out
products is just working from home
or just work from home and need to mail
stuff stance.com can handle it all with
ease
and grace simply use your computer to
print official us postage 24
7 on any letter any package any class of
mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready
just leave it with your mail carrier
schedule a pickup or drop it
in a mailbox it's that simple and like i
said with stamps.com you get a great
discount
uh talking about five cents off every
stamp
and up to 62 off of usps
and ups shipping rates stamps.com is a
no-brainer you save time
you save money and you support the show
you love and would never
want to see diminish
in any way
right now for our listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial
plus free postage and
a digital scale without any long-term
commitment
just go to stamps.com clom
just go to stamps.com someone's like c
dot c-l-o-m go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type nh3 that's
stamps.com
enter h3
welcome back super troopers i hope
you've got your
fupa trooper flags on and you're ready
for battle
last week we got into a little bit of a
controversy actually
because of my comments regarding the
regenerative properties
of the female anatomy trying to put it
delicately nice
and um you know what i'm just going to
own up to
a lot of people were upset and i i feel
like
maybe either i didn't communicate well
or or i mean
i was that wasn't my intention to say
that like but but you know what i i i
yeah yeah yeah i was wrong okay it's not
my place
um it's an antiquated thing i mean
look ultimately i was just wondering how
long it takes
not to say that it's blasted forever
regardless
a lot of people were mad at me including
mike
the boyfriend of lana from the impulsive
podcast who tweeted at me
he said and i quote
i'll put it up on screen he says
dear at h3h3 h3h3productions
i saw your segment about lana on today's
upload
i'm not going to get into your
disgusting rhetoric
as it's your brand to spew hatred
disguised as comedy
but she retired three years ago if
you're gonna call yourself a podcast
host
at least do some research
what do you got first of all there's a
lot obviously to unpack here but
what do you guys think about my brand
being hate
disguised as comedy
i'd like to think that's not true i mean
it's a pretty bold statement
you know yeah you think he means like
hate as in like
being a hater or does he literally mean
like you're a hateful person
a man racist when he says spew hatred i
think it's certain
that doesn't sound like oh you're a
hater bro that sounds like you are a
hateful person
yeah that seems a little extreme i feel
like from his perspective
probably being like uh logan
paul's best friend
we've criticized logan paul so that's
probably what they think about us
that we're just haters yeah i guess from
his perspective you might say although
logan
previously when they're discussing us is
pretty like cool
but mike is always kind of making it
mike is always uh
he's let me go let me continue on
he actually has nice things to say about
you ela he says also
shout out to ela for being the voice of
reason
so i agree with that i mean i was like
hey at least he likes one of us
and homie with the long hair zach get
ready
saying he would never [ __ ] a porn star i
seen your type
buddy you would pay 5k to smell my
girl's panties
zach what did you think of the good bro
being on the receiving end
yeah um i'm cool bro
i don't i don't want to do that i don't
want to swallow your girl's panties
all i said was like i wouldn't have sex
with her why do you gotta attack me for
that well hang on you all you said was
that you wouldn't have
you wouldn't date or [ __ ] a porn star
yeah
exactly which i think is and and i think
like that's that's not a controversial
opinion i mean again he you are
and so mike um he seems to be a little
bit defensive
frankly about the issue he does and he
also says
to another person and the thread i think
that
like he doesn't care about good
jabs at them but like he expected us to
do more research if we were going to
talk about it so much but
it wasn't really a planned out segment
first of all it was just kind of like
you made a random random joke and then
it became this whole conversation
because i made it
i made a big deal out of it because i
just
it just happened at the moment but it's
not really something that we researched
and planned but i'll talk about it okay
but you know what i've done mike
because you came at me
guess what i've done i've done my
research now
and now let's talk about mike and lana
because you want to throw a shot you
want to be the big man
hateful rhetoric do some research
zach sweet young golden zack if you go
after sweet young golden zack
you better meet me in the octagon fool
cause i won't drop that
uh what's that crazy uh headlock they do
in mma
there's one that's like the ultimate
kill shot the triple cross
the triple cross school bomb dive death
joke
i'm going to [ __ ] you up mike with what
i appreciate it's worth
spending money oh dude nobody talks [ __ ]
about
zach and by the way it was totally
unwarranted you didn't deserve that
thank you yeah he uh he was super off
off his
line oh but you said you didn't like him
maybe that's what he did started zach
i i don't like him but but hello he's a
public figure you're entitled to not
like him
hello dude welcome to the internet mike
people are entitled not to like you you
[ __ ]
guess who else doesn't like he does
let's talk
he just blabbers his [ __ ] mouth all
right go ahead go off
we just got like a lot of the time no
frame of reference
and he just got to shut the [ __ ] up
quite frankly
because he's annoying there you go
zach's wow speech
speaking his mind but zach is also
actually a fan of the logan paul channel
right i am so that gets harder
yeah next
so somebody clapped back at mike on
twitter he said he didn't even say
anything bad about
uh lana zach the guy with the long hair
just didn't like you not everyone's
going to be a fan go off anna
so what he didn't know your girl didn't
do porn anymore and you expect everyone
to know
mike i love your podcast but i feel like
this is kind of immature
sorry shredder when did you make that
alt zach
[Laughter]
anna0282765 is not a halt
it's an anagram i dare you
mike responded if you're going to speak
confidently on a topic do your research
that's it
really really i didn't speak confidently
about anything the whole conversation
was just
us yeah questioning each other really
i don't recall being like it was just a
random joke that ethan made and i was
basically
telling him look this may be a joke but
you may want to think about who it's
going to appeal to
so first of all i want to point out all
that was there really you didn't say
anything bad about
anyone i agree i have pure i'm pure of
heart and soul
everyone's entitled to their opinion
mike you don't have to [ __ ] your gym
shorts every time someone says they
don't like it
i like it you've never seen
dude you don't want piss zach off bro
he'll [ __ ] bring out the
guitar hero zack is a zoomer it's hard
to piss him off
right yeah okay so you want research you
want research mike
let's start here um first of all
i find it interesting that you didn't
take any issue with the fact
that um your what i said about
the regenerative properties of the
female body no you didn't care about
that
the only thing you cared about mike was
insinuation that she's still having sex
with other men for
profession and and so i find it very
interesting that you focused on that
yet by the way the the main accusation
in our podcast
is that your whole crew is spreading
covid
knowingly and somehow the fact
that i thought lana was still doing porn
was more obscene to you than the fact
that you
are personally spreading a deadly
disease
do you tell your guests by the way when
they show up and sit a foot away from
your uncovered mouth
that you were in contact with somebody
who tested positive
you [ __ ] back me up yeah
okay let's keep going this is a hidden
episode
well i'm the guy's a [ __ ] bump you
better do your research bro
i'm not done yet i'm not that angry i
just want to make it clear i'm just
i'm just it's a shame because we were
just starting to say
nice things about the poll the lp
i was not the jp i think we were all
starting to like logan but this whole
thing about with tanner where he's like
i don't care hit me with that soundbite
of logan saying he doesn't care
hit the clock dan you have a clock sound
effect
i think you do actually just got tested
that's jake
you don't have logan i don't have logan
i never pulled it oh my god
well because we watched it everything
mike said about you is true zack
can you grab logan oh man oh man
anyway logan said when tanner was like
yo bro i have covet and i was hanging
out with you
he was like i don't give a [ __ ] and then
the next day he does a podcast
so meanwhile uh mike is so
upset that i didn't know that she
retired
three years ago retired okay so maybe
you can explain to me
uh why she posted to her pornhub account
in april that doesn't seem like
retirement oh mike says well she's not
having sex with other dudes that's
technically retirement
okay she's doing like uh she's with
girls she's doing solo stuff i mean
that's still porn dude
what what am i what how what are we
splitting hairs here
oh take if you're not thinking a dude
that you're retired from porn
what
i mean we're not following that closely
oh yeah i'm not i
all i see mike is that she's been number
one on pornhub
every time i go to beat off and i'm like
wow
she's number one all the time so like
it's pretty reasonable to assume that
she's still making porn and by the way
she's a beautiful girl i mean
that's just a compliment to her i don't
know why you get so
like this is all coming from the fact
that she's that big in the porn in this
yeah he's huge he should be
he's dating number one but he got so
effect i think he just i think he's so
insecure about dating a porn star
that this basically this small
insinuation
of which is like clearly a very
reasonable mistake to make
yeah is is uh somehow he he was so upset
that i think he's just really insecure
about the whole thing and he doesn't
want people to think like
that threatens his masculinity that she
might be having sex with other men
for her profession and so he needs to
make it very clear to everybody no
she retired and by retired i mean
she just doesn't have sex with other
dudes but she still makes porn actively
all the time on her only fans
so technically she's not retired what
does retired mean even in this context
you better grab some of that kirkland
two-ply because he's [ __ ] his gym
shorts dude
wow wow say no more
you know it's funny because even on her
only fans as recently as like
may she was posting um videos of her
with another dude and yes we went to our
only fans and did research for this
segment because mike
like you said if you're gonna speak you
better know
[ __ ] so yes she was even posting dudes
with uh
what videos with other dudes as recently
as may it was like an old unpublished
video
right but she's still posting it right
so excuse
me excuse me
for insinuating that
well let's keep going mike because i've
done my research what we keep going oh
there's more baby there's more
now mike let's talk about disgusting
rhetoric
let's see what mike has said about his
own girlfriend
and women in general
listen to mike say it for himself and
you tell me disgusting rhetoric when you
hear it
speak for the commenters and stuff does
it in any way bother you that your
girlfriend is married or has done
anal sex with large black men on camera
not um
that she's married all right so two
separate questions
so how do you how do you want me to
where do you want to start i don't care
all right so so the man by the way he's
35 and he was born in january so he's
old as [ __ ]
he's older than me he's older than me
she's 35. he's 35 we're both
you're both 35. yeah but he's older than
me by four months
okay but why are you calling all this
[ __ ] because he's the older he's old as
[ __ ] he's older than me he's the oldest
loser on youtube
no that's a reach
he's the oldest you're the same age no
he's four months older that's the same
age he's
four months older i'm just saying
say like oh i'm six and a half
i'm just saying technically he's older
than me he's old as [ __ ] i'm not the
oldest biggest dumpiest loser ever
okay yeah but ethan doesn't [ __ ] his gym
shorts mike does
watch this is that something that
actually happens zach are you making it
no
he's just the type of dude to [ __ ] his
[ __ ] shorts
and in this hypothetical situation does
the turds like fall out the pant leg
while he's running it's a [ __ ] thing
[Music]
anyway let's listen talking about having
fun okay
hateful rhetoric let's talk about let's
listen to mike
the marriage thing i don't care my
girl's naked on the internet too
the ma the marriage thing um is
a different topic let's start let's
start with the anal sex with the black
man and
let's let's start his name is tattooed
on her ass yeah okay so let's let's
start with the second one
ah logan's so uncomfortable
oh i think somebody got too hot for lp
he's gonna sail back he's gonna sit back
are you ready for this i'm gonna lay
this out for you
the [ __ ] that i did before i got on the
scene
oh yeah was so [ __ ] dirty
and so [ __ ] bad there is nothing
i don't know but like i don't know how
he's gonna talk i mean i couldn't even
imagine it sounds bad but that's not
even what i'm talking
about yeah pretty much anyone
what to to the benefit of mike i will
give him credit he's a recovering
drug and alcoholic okay well then
i have nothing to comment on that okay
yeah no i was just wondering i don't
know anything but
let's not get sidetracked let's focus on
the hateful uh rhetoric
could have done in their past that would
change the way i look at them as a
person
nothing bro right oh i did sorry i
[ __ ] up
the question was how do you feel about
your girlfriend having sex with other
men on camera
he was more vulgar obviously in the way
he phrased it but i'm trying to keep it
pg-13
point do you know how many girls in this
city have [ __ ] their way to the
position they're currently in
and didn't get paid a dollar for it this
i mean that's kind of misogynistic how
many girls in this city have [ __ ]
their way
into the position they're in that seems
like a kind of [ __ ] up statement to me
it's a little bit hateful towards women
if i if i was uh
looking closely but here they can he
continues not really
yeah that's i don't really see why even
make that comparison
and the fact that women had to do that
is also a big part of the metoo movement
that is hopefully going to change all
that
eli he goes on to say like women weren't
happy to do that
no mike no it's not a
and no a lot it's not a lot of
successful women too
either yeah i don't know what he's
talking about like well here ila uh
uh listen he he goes on very big
browser's contract on the table to
restart
in in the next month she's not doing it
wow so she she she actually
has has is done do you think you would
be able to stomach it if she was
actually like no
going to work doing porn then coming
back home to you no
so absolutely not the man mike
is not down and for what he exec
you said you wouldn't want to do that he
came
at you mike himself has said that he
wouldn't do it i don't see where's the
problem but listen what he says next
so we so obviously you know i've i've
had
flings with other women pretty big no
other pretty big adult actresses
you know what i'm saying like that
didn't go the same distance as as lana
has and we didn't have the same
you know feelings for each other
everybody's at a different place in her
life
for sure but the reason is is because
they are still
very active in the scene and so like yo
she has a past
she took a whole bunch of [ __ ] dicks
just like every other [ __ ] girl in
the city
hers what on camera
and i think it's a very i think it takes
a very
specific man to be okay with that [ __ ] i
said it i said on our show the other day
if you compared her bodies to my bodies
yeah holy [ __ ] nothing
mentioned that holy [ __ ] i i have you
[ __ ] homeless women
horrible bro i used to do terrible
terrible [ __ ] things so
i that sounds i just don't know
something to be proud of yeah i don't
know how to play it it doesn't sound
like he's proud of it
but he says he said he said quote she's
taken a ton of dicks like every other
girl in the city
yeah he's just joking dude
well i'm just saying bro if you're gonna
throw shots i mean damn that's that's
that's that sounds a lot more hateful
and misogynistic than anything i said
which was a simple question of the
regenerative and elastic properties of
really pursuit of knowledge without any
hateful intent
mike
then of course uh keemstar suddenly
loves mike as soon as mike calls me out
on twitter
keemstar is suddenly mike's best friend
which is just so funny because actually
what's funny is
keemstar has actually talked a lot of
[ __ ] about mike but all of a sudden
keemstar goes mike you just worry about
your happiness
all of a sudden he's like a self-help
guru people are always going to tear you
down but you are
winning i have criticized you more than
almost
anyone on the internet but i respect
your hustle
and i just want you to know that good
guy keemstar yeah
all of a sudden but then of course mike
has to respond because
and now it's all good feel good love pow
wow shooting on ethan
appreciate that keem i'm not mad at all
honestly
this is just pro to pro criticism
i'm not perfect at research either but
if i'm going to dive
balls deep into a topic
i hope to at least understand the core
points of said topic
he missed the mark today bro first of
all i wouldn't consider myself a pro and
i don't know what the [ __ ] you are
you're a professional coattail writer
like seriously what the [ __ ] like he's
so self-congratulatory
and he missed the mark today
oh man i let mike down i'm so confident
like
again the the mark was um specifically
just
not knowing that she was quote retired
that's what i missed
because to us the conversation was
completely different yeah he
he he took his only takeaway really was
that
we were actually under the assumption
that she is still
doing the work that you see around the
internet a lot right
so fine we should have known better but
we were under that assumption and to us
and like the interesting conversation is
when you date someone who's doing that
work
what is that like he had no comment on
that but they're not actually in that
situation either
yeah but like the misunderstanding
considering the fact she's posting to
her
her pornhub account and her only fans
actively
i mean again for him to get so
wild about the fact that i missed the
mark today by
my lack of research is is weird and he's
clearly just super
insecure about it uh with that being
said
you know i do want to actually i'm not
done here's the thing right like i'm not
even done
like because i wanted to make sure i did
all the proper research
um you know to so so that i could
really make him proud of me i don't want
to miss the mark again the first two
times like i thought like no way i'm
gonna
she's talking about the first few times
she had sex with mike this guy
keep having sex with him because it was
just so so bad yeah i remember i was
like this is so
awkward and like horrible we like
we like tried to like we like tried to
like not force it but it was like
interesting he couldn't please her
i wonder if that has anything to do with
the insecurities
uh well at least i may have been on to
something right like i mean you have
performance issues when you as a man
trying to follow up
because not just like the people she's
had sex with but she
she she is an experienced woman
well she's a professional she's a
professional
sex haver if i i would be i would be
intimidated
right and so like i i don't feel it so
obviously you know the guy
was having some performance issues she
was like oh this sex is so awful
you know but anyway he goes on to say uh
let's see what mike says here just doing
my research my due diligence
average person like the average person
would be like oh my god like she's
she's been with all these guys before me
like how do i measure up you know what
i'm saying
what i said and then to get on your high
horse on twitter
judge me you just literally said the
average person would say that
as long as she's telling me after our
sex that it was incredible and that like
and i'm asking her what i can change
anyway um any thoughts any summaries did
i do good how do we do
was my research i mean after seeing all
of that i mean i
i don't necessarily feel bad for him but
i mean i think you're
right that this i think his uh
snapping at you was um rooted in a
little bit of insecurity like you said
and uh
and i don't know i i feel a little
bad for him this is probably something
he struggles with it might be an issue
in their relationship
i don't know right maybe that's too far
to even speculate well i think that if
you're gonna date a porn star you just
gotta
you gotta because like he's pr he's
obviously pressuring her
or but maybe in in in uh directly
because he's saying if you go back to
doing this then
it's over and so may i mean look that's
her profession she might want to do that
and if you're not willing to do it with
her then
she's she's not being able to deliver
the full experience to
to the fans that that like her content
so
i do feel like that's a kind of an
unfair stipulation it's like if you're
going to date a porn star you've got to
be right or die
you you go with the whole package right
and so he obviously has this kind of
macho insecure thing about like being
cucked or whatever
because it's kind of what it is like
another dude [ __ ] your girl and then
comes home to you
that's that's the life that you kind of
sign up all i can say is
a full-fledged apology from mike to the
h3 podcast
what about a gal what what would you
like him to apologize for zach
[ __ ] his gym shorts
and not doing his research yeah he
didn't do his research first of all
by the way you don't like him so i do
not like him but he's
got an apology for that yeah why should
zach apologize for not liking him
but what is he what is he apologizing
for
to zach you know he accused me of lack
of research but in the same tweet
he refers to zach as homie with the long
hair it could have taken him three
seconds to figure out zack's name
unless his goal of course was to be
disrespectful which
leads back to the original point of the
criticism which he laid at me which is
spreading hate
so which is it mike are you doing bad
research are you being hateful towards
zach
yeah so you need to tell me which one it
is
and then apologize for the one it isn't
that's what he owes us an apology for
and
finally tick-tock
is being threatened to be banned off the
place
the face of the planet earth tick-tock
the beloved uh blossoming app that has
taken the world by storm
actually really taking the world by
storm i heard it's got 100 million users
in the united states that's like
one-third of everybody
i'm sad to say i'm not in the ranks of
tick tock but i do feel like i'm missing
out
mm-hmm me too everyone's having fun
there you know
dancing singing
flirting everybody's on tick tock man
i just can't i just can't bring myself
to invest the thing is like you have to
kind of put in effort to be on tick tock
or on twitter you can be like
i i made a stinky fart
and people be like yes but you know what
i mean
you don't have to post well i have a
ghost account
but do you actually spend time on
tick-tock no
me neither i try i try you know but i
feel like
you kind of have to invest some time for
it to get to know what you like because
it's just not that personalized for me
right now and it's just like a lot of
random crap
so but but i do try anyway tick tock
president trump has put his foot down on
tick tock
tick tock actually we've spoken about
this previously is owned by
bite dance which is a chinese company
and there's
been a lot of fear um
among policy makers in the united states
that
they're sharing data with the chinese
government and let's face it that is
all but probable i mean knowing the
chinese government those dudes are
shady and uh they totally would do that
i mean they have a like
an authoritarian total grasp on all
business and industry there there's no
there's no standards i mean yeah so
i'm sure that china is is spying
uh actually and india uh
banned tik tok recently too and tick
tock was huge in india also had like
over 100 million users so
this has precedent um
trump of course announced this on social
media
when he said he would ban tick tock by
executive action
as soon as saturday
now this would of course deprive us of
great content
you know you always wonder where's colby
person in all these legends of youtube
they're on tick tock 835
000 likes is that views is view the same
as a like
no well then how many views does it have
i think it is i don't think so
then how many votes the hearts have
because it must have a lot of views if
that's how he likes it as
he's still rocking the gold lambo i love
it can you watch my car real quick i'll
be back like right now
just like what you really okay i got you
i got you wow
this is a collab with the russian twins
bro where's my keys where's my car would
you like it where's my keys
epic i hate when this happens kobe
person
has is still making the bomb ass content
5.6 million views wait how do you see
that i just don't think it shows it on
desktop he's probably looking up
how many views um 5.6 million
whoa people are so dumb on tick tock
actually i have noticed that like
they're pretty big
that's impressive the views on tick tock
are huge man
because it's short form so you probably
watch it a few times
yeah what are we doing we got to get on
tick tock we need to podcast clips there
but even just the likes alone that's a
lot
and he has 6.4 million followers on
tickets so that's what's up co they all
these guys these facebook prankers
always move to like the lowest combin
denominator they were on facebook now
they're all on tick tock
so that's kobe person and actually while
i'm at it the twins from russia
the they shot a video in the same exact
location
around this parking lot in only four
seconds what are we betting on
sure you guys can give a million dollars
if you lose yeah
let's do it one two three go
you're not gonna be able to do it no way
[Music]
no way yeah it was so quick right yo it
was so quick man
[Music]
oh there's music playing we can't play
the music
yeah we're so quick all right take the
car dude
so we're at risk of losing you know
these pranksters have found a new home
we need to protect them at all costs
leaders of both
parties of the united states have
criticized the app's owners
bite dance for allegedly sharing its
user data with the chinese government
of course they have denied it but that's
exactly what wendy the pill would say
winnie the pooh of course is chairman c
who
looks like winnie the pooh what the hell
was that reference he looks just like
one of the people yeah
we've talked about it he'll throw your
ass in jail for saying that which is
awesome that's why you gotta love
america
because people say a lot worse about
trump every day and they don't go to
jail so hey
god bless america right um also notable
that in early july
uh tick-tock was banned in india as i
said
they had 119 million users in india when
it was banned so it was a huge deal
there
actually microsoft announced that they
wanted to buy
tick-tock for the chinese market so they
would take over tick-tock
it wouldn't change at all they would
just basically take it over
for the u.s and um but
so it was all on shaky grounds because
trump was like i'm going to ban tick
tock and micro slaves like i'm going to
buy it bro
uh they said it's they're committed to
acquiring
tick-tock but they need approval from
the u.s
government to do so
and so uh you know what what's funny is
another
theory for why trump is hell-bent on
banning tick-tock
is that people on tick-tock have been
mercifully mercifully
merciful mercilessly
not with mercy without mercy
goofing on trump you guys remember the
tulsa rally flop
trump said there's going to be millions
of people there they had this whole
overflow
and basically like 8 000 people showed
up it was like a total flop
well tick tock had a huge hand in making
that happen with videos like this one
here
that were going viral all over tick tock
guys donald trump
i actually heard that theory but i never
saw
the the videos that people made about it
so this one
here's one here's one for example all
you have to do is give your phone number
and you can get two tickets so i got two
tickets
but i totally forgot that i have to pick
every individual piece of land off of my
room
floor and then sort them by size so i
can't believe it for friday
oh well i already got the tickets
and i accidentally just verified it
too so that means there's gonna be at
least two empty spots
guys that's awful you should be really
careful going to do this you know
just in case you know you can't make it
you know you don't want a bunch of
empty seats and another thing guys if
you are doing it make sure to use the
right
zip codes just so that they know you are
in the area
so i gotta say that's a pretty epic
troll
like i mean damn they got got so bad
because people
were literally reserved millions of
seats
and only 6 000 people showed up i mean
that is
legendary troll yeah trump's uh campaign
manager his name's escaping me right now
but he was really hyping up
the fact that so many people were going
to be there and then uh they canned him
like a week after that
most people think because wow what a
goof this was so
yeah it was it was quite a goof i have
to say and i think these kids probably
had a huge part in and curbing their
expectation or like encouraging their
expectations
and then there's other people like sarah
cooper sarah cooper who was just
she does these uh lip syncing
trump tick tocks and she's just
she's so good at it whatever you think
about trump you really have to give this
girl
don't forget all the credit in the world
this is hilarious and when i saw her it
really is
when i first saw her on twitter i was
like
she's gonna be huge and she has been
huge i feel like she's literally
actually getting to him at this point i
just i can't stop watching these
and they're so simple but it's just too
funny
so here's one than anybody in the world
but why because we do more testing when
you test you have a case
when you test you find something is
wrong with people
if we didn't do any testing we would
have very few cases
they don't want to write that it's
common sense so we test
much more many many times south korea
you hear about
i spoke with the president of south
korea spoke with many different
presidents prime ministers
i can't believe what we've been able to
do on testing they can't believe what
we've been able to do in ventilators
we're sending them ventilators other
countries
italy spain
other countries france is having
tremendous problems tremendous problems
with ventilators i mean don't forget
it's we have more cases than anybody in
the world but she's
like exploded so i think a tick tock
generally like all the zoomers
are just totally clowning on trump there
and
and
you know i do think trump is that petty
frankly speaking um
because he's he's threatening to take
quick action to ban tick-tock
but then he set a date he gave an
ultimatum to microsoft he said
you have till september 15th to
cut a deal with microsoft at which point
it's going to be
out of business but here's the other
strange wrinkle in this he says
um he says
so right now they don't have any rights
unless we give it to them
so if we're going to give them the
rights then it has to come into this
country
oh wait well no no that's not he said
he said here uh in an unusual
declaration
trump said any deal would have to
include a substantial amount of money
coming to the u.s treasury i've never
heard of anything like that my whole
life
why would the government with the united
states government need to be paid
in order to buy a company
from what i understand uh the rationale
is that because he has put
um this diplomatic pressure
essentially by by creating the scenario
where they're about to get banned
he has contributed to creating the value
of tick tock and therefore feels like
the us government is entitled to a cut
of that because
the value is being driven up because of
his
ultimatum yeah but i don't really since
when does the government
collect equity i don't think that that's
a thing
you know so to go on to the conspiracy
theory that he just wants to shut down
tick tock this could be just a caveat
an impossible caveat to ensure that it
shuts down we'll see on set by september
15th
well i don't know the uh the microsoft
um in their
statement uh they did kind of tip their
hat to that
saying that they understood and agreed
that the the treasury would need its cut
so i guess they're willing to play ball
isn't that just taxes don't they always
get a cut of everything
not direct to the treasury i don't think
i don't know it's all over my head okay
well there you go
so it just it
well frankly speaking i would feel a lot
more
happy knowing that tick tock was owned
by an american company because
uh i think the chinese are definitely
spying on us through tick tock
like for sure there's even been like big
companies like what was it google or
or a company like that apple i don't
know that
prohibited their employees from having
tick tock installed on their phones
um interesting yeah so that should tell
you all you need to know really
and then of course there are people that
are very sad about the tragic ending of
tick tock and
zach please sound bite this anywhere
tick tock is our home trump has no need
to ban tick-tock
just because the haters
tick-tock is my home and everyone's home
hell yeah
it's our tick-tock his chest looks
airbrushed like face-to-face
is our problem trump has no need to ban
tick-tock
just because they sound like that well
i am certainly hoping that we can do
everything in our power
to save tick-tock and not only to save
tick tock but to make turn
make tick tock american again
i do think a lot of kids love it so much
and they've already had such a terrible
year 2020.
no we can't do it to them we can't do it
to them
they've already lost fine yeah and then
they're like oh we lost fine but here's
tick-tock
yeah you know we're whole again we found
purpose and direction in life
and now donald trump's going to come out
here by executive order and take away
the only thing they have left
no yeah i'll tell you what if trump bans
tick-tock he's gonna lose
he's gonna lose a lot of well he'd
probably well they don't really vote
yeah well right they don't
overwhelmingly they don't vote
that might that might rally the troops
that might get the young kids out there
to be like
this is where i draw the line take time
baby's in cages
i sleep tick-tock band i vote
no i'm just kidding i don't know i mean
he does put babies in cages
i mean like that is something he does
i mean there's pictures and stuff i mean
i don't know if you want to get into
that yeah
one of these things but it's one of
those conversations it is definitely
something that is happening
now right i just
once you go there but it's a whole
conversation admittedly i don't know
that much yeah
i've seen some photos and stuff so i
probably should be more concerned about
it but there you have it
ethan come on can you just wrap it up
without getting into some [ __ ]
um anyway tomorrow's episode is going to
be
super fun we have again
uh chad and jt the party bros these are
absolute
legends i'm super excited to have them
on tomorrow it could be in the midst of
absolute bro legends spreading good
vibes
and raising stoke levels
so we will see you guys then and um so
three episodes this week so stand by
we're gonna have a lot of fun and uh
hope to see you guys
in the members page where i'll be
sending nudes to members
only that's one of the additional
benefits i didn't realize but whole
shots but they're so close that it's
just black
can that be epic they just take a black
that's my butthole but
it's so dark you can't really tell
it's kind of a good idea maybe i should
start you should start only friends
yeah it's on members but it's just all i
specialize in really close bottles
so close you can't tell what it is i'll
post one of those um
for the members tomorrow oh cool
i'll probably have to be the one to edit
that so youtube will like ban
our ship i'll just take a picture of my
hands it's all dark
and then youtube's like no hey this is
jumping back just a bit but i just
wanted to ask you
with this whole tick tock thing and
microsoft buying them you know
microsoft's pretty notorious for like uh
running things into the ground really i
didn't know they had that right
yeah they they kind of you know they've
had a lot of false
starts on various projects remember
there was windows phone for a while
and like yeah everybody did that yeah
well there's lots of things like that
so i just kind of wonder if like they're
going to go through all this trouble
there's going to be all this drama about
they're going to buy it and then within
a year tick tock will be
myspace and everybody's skype that would
be pretty sad
well they were on skype skype was like
the number one app
right ever yeah then microsoft bought it
and it's like how did you ruin skype
everybody loves skype
and now everybody hates skype because
yeah is so annoying to use
right i don't know how they could do
that though they would really didn't
they just
flop uh mixer right mixer was a flop too
that was facebook i thought no no no
that was microsoft oh so they ruin
everything
that's what i'm kind of saying i like
microsoft is on a
long losing streak well if they're smart
they would just
buy it and like it's just proof that if
you made
one great software that doesn't mean
that you can
just go ahead and make whatever else
i mean microsoft is kind of a big deal
but is that all they've done i don't
know have they done more than just make
windows it's like ubiquitous but that's
kind of part of windows
but the zune but also yeah zoom was
another
thing that flopped what are wait what is
that they just make
exactly what it is let's see let's look
up what is
like their version of the ipod yeah it
was their ipod
competitor oh i remember that i heard of
it hold on let me do some re what does
microsoft own because i feel like they
must have done something right
they do i mean obviously they do but
they they've had a lot of ls
too over the years so i kind of just
wonder if uh
guys i think that's a valid question
i think so too i'm looking at a list of
companies they've bought
um a lot of them i don't recognize
they're there
i'm trying to find ones that i did i hot
mail that didn't really go anywhere no
hot meal was a big deal i had a hot mail
once upon a time i did
yeah we all did when you when i met you
either hotmail all day
hotmail is uh msn which i think a lot of
people
well xbox i mean the xbox has has been
successful
yeah the new xbox looks like [ __ ] though
well well
but to be honest with you i'm kind of a
ps
playstation all the way that's what i'm
saying they got all that
games yeah yeah xbox is a huge
accomplishment yeah
um i'm trying to see what else they got
here they have a
[ __ ] god ungodly amount of properties
the thing
a lot of the things that are successful
are like enterprise they're for business
and you don't really
care about it yeah exactly but yeah a
lot of their public
facing uh endeavors have crashed and
burned pretty i cannot believe
israel the amount of [ __ ] they own
get go and desktop center like i don't
know what the [ __ ] that is they might be
super successful
whale communicate i mean there's so much
[ __ ] yeah jellyfish.com what the hell is
that
jellyfish.com um
big park skype yeah see you later skype
used to be cool but now you suck but
yeah i just wonder
nokia nokia they kind of ruined nokia
and nokia used to be big
the phone company and uh yeah right hold
on
for the windows phone thing and all of
that kind of crashed and burned
hold on i got to give it up to them on
this one uh mojang
minecraft they definitely that was the
winner
so they won on that one good point okay
well
and and like in the tech field yeah i
don't know they kind of have some mixed
race a lot of israel flags what are all
those
um i'm still looking really i'm actually
captivated
compulsion games playground games undead
labs ninja theory do you know any of
those companies
ninja theory sounds familiar oh they own
us
obsidian entertainment i didn't actually
know that those guys make great games
black aisle uh those guys make like
fallout don't they
uh it's sort of
they made um here i'll tell you
everything they've made
i believe that that's the company that
came out knights of the old republic
the original fallout new vegas right new
vegas yeah
pillars of eternity that was a great
game you played that one
pillars of eternity too so they're
they're they're yeah i'm really
interested by this i don't know if
anyone's with me but it's the end of the
episode so it's all good
double fine productions uh those
psychonauts that's tim
schaefer's company that's a big deal
okay yeah well in the gaming space
obviously they've had a
like you pointed out with the xbox it's
a decent success
so they i guess yeah they're very hit
and miss
a lot of hits tick tock is going to be
one of their biggest properties at this
point if they buy it man i wonder how
much they're gonna have to shell out for
that
it's gonna be billions for sure it's
gonna be a lot apparently they're
not just buying uh american tick tock
but like
u.s australia new zealand and canada i
think was made golly that's gonna be
like i don't know how much like 100
billion i mean i don't know how much
that's just gonna be a lot of money
is that like uh a really lucky situation
for them
that's what trump's saying because like
i think it is has been
sell it or [ __ ] off forever yeah and so
they're being forced to sell it and
frankly tick tock is still
early and it's developmental rise yeah
and so i don't know that you can even
fairly uh judge its value
yeah so microsoft is definitely it's a
buyer's market because what choice do
they have it's like
either get paid or get nothing right
so yeah i mean that's right which i
think is right when i
the point i was trying to make earlier
poorly about
trump wanting the government to get a
cut i guess that's what it is
he's putting the screws on them
microsoft is going to get a
good deal and therefore he feels
entitled to a cut of it
but isn't that [ __ ] up to acknowledge
that it's almost like it's like some
weird
mob [ __ ] where it's like it's kind of
he's like listen
it'd be nice if if uh tick tock had to
sell
yeah i mean at least is gonna help the
country then
it's not gonna help the country it's no
it's gonna hurt the country the money
that they oh well i mean it's it's dude
even if the u.s one gets
a couple billion dollars i mean that's
like literally like pennies to the
government that is kind of
dropping the bucket i'll tell you i mean
but you know what i mean yeah everything
helps i guess i mean what is that like
one or two
of fighter jets i mean really how much
do those fighter jets cost that they
love to buy
tomahawks yeah i mean yeah that [ __ ]
goes a long way
a couple of fighter jets that will sit
vacant for 30 years
this is good well anyways i know we were
kind of done with that topic and i
brought it back but oh [ __ ] there's a
wait there's a whole another
list oh really wait hold the phone
more more microsoft stuff these are
these are huge ones
wait why does it say you can correct me
why does it say
apple they don't they're not involved
with apple
oh they have steak and apple did you
know that
you know they have a billion dollar
steak and now and then
microsoft saved apple actually i didn't
realize that that
was still ongoing oh they own a they own
a billion dollars of comcast as well
yeah i mean a lot of these companies
have a have a stake in each other so
five billion dollars in a t
jesus what the [ __ ] tell a west
communications
best buy
facebook they own 240 million dollars
that's really not that much
barnes and noble oh that's a tough one
that's a tough one
they have 600 million in barnes noble
yeah i can't believe how
they're everywhere what is going on i
don't know
that's that's kind of how it works all
these big companies they know
ticketmaster everywhere
cnbc usa networks liberty media
okay this is getting scary yeah how like
these companies
they're like uh it's like voldemort
spreading as horror crooks everywhere
it's like
it's like they're unkillable at this
point they they have seeds and
and like tendrils and as so many parts
of society it's like
they're they're they're immortal i mean
it's it's creepy
so um while we're doing uber aol
yeah that's just annoying though oh it's
no good
um pewdiepie is trending now because
apparently spotify got licked so people
are criticizing him for what kind of
music he listens to wait whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what his
private
playlist got leaked and people are
[ __ ] on him i think so that's what
i'm understanding
i don't know if it's some because i was
looking at this a few minutes ago yeah
you're on break and uh
i mean maybe some people are [ __ ] on
him but it's more so that he's into
a lot of um lgbt artists
uh that's a problem i don't think it's a
problem i think it's just came as a
shock to a lot of people and they're
like
if you look at his like top artists it's
uh it's
it's just kind of surprising it's
probably not what you would have guessed
i don't know
what um oh this oh this is his top
wait so somebody hacked his [ __ ] and
then looked at his top artist
that's so bizarre it might not have been
hacked maybe they just
found his playlist or something and
realized it was i just don't understand
how is this even a conversation
i guess because people assume that
pewdiepie is like a racist [ __ ] bag
but that he listens to lbgt he's not i'm
just saying what these people yeah the
same people who would be shocked by that
are are the same people who would be
surprised by that
um interesting so who are these artists
listening to
like here's a big tweet the fact that
pewdiepie is trending because of his
hyper pop
taste that leans into yeah it's kind of
a sub genre
leans into lgbt movement and the fact
that he
has changed from his past but people
will still bring his drama from four
years ago
is tiring
yeah that's kind of true well anyways so
i guess that's what that's all about
well people are i see some people
applauding his excellent taste of music
i i for one i have to say he's in pretty
deep because i'm not familiar with any
of these artists
although i'm not really a music fanatic
ian do you know any of these artists
i just pulled it up i i know a couple
what do you think do you think
sophie before but i've seen uh two of
them
in concert really oh okay which ones
uh sophie and slater um
well you had to see slater it's like
that's like
i like most of these guys yeah so
you're co-signing good taste good taste
there you go ian knows i mean ian knows
ian knows everything about music he's
our keeper of culture and history of
youth and euthanasia in the words of ali
g
i think people are just kind of thrown
off because a lot of these artists do
have they're a little cult following
little artists with a lot of die hard
fans and a lot of them are lgbt
um people who support these artists so
yeah you know what
i've always got the sense that pewdiepie
is like socially very progressive and
and liberal and i feel like whatever
people think about him
isn't really the truth about who he is
as a person i feel like
privately he's a very different person
than what people think of him and
i guess this is kind of proof of that
behind the curtain um which is kind of
ironic because everybody thinks like
that he's just this radical reactionary
i actually went to when i saw one of
these artists sophie
um uh some dude tried to [ __ ] me in the
bathroom
what tell me about that i just choked up
my sodie pop when you said that
i did not expect you to say that at all
well like as you can tell by the
response like i said
they're big in the gay community these
artists and
i was there and i went to the bathroom
i'm washing my hands and this guy comes
by me and he um
he like puts his hand on my shoulder and
he's like you want to get in the stall
really quick
and i was like um
this was i think the artist charlie xcx
and then sophie was performing too um
and i was like oh i'm not gay and he was
like but you like
charlie xcx and sophie you're really
and he was like are you sure you don't
want to go in really quick i'm like
i'm sure i'm fine it's like reverse
homophobia right there
yeah dude it's crazy that he just
assumes anyone in the bathroom wants to
[ __ ] him too
what was he a good looking guy i don't
remember
no i can't i can't recall but um
were you tempted he was down on his
knees the whole time so he didn't really
get a good look at him
it's kind of interesting with these
artists because like i don't know it's
interesting if you're a fan of these
artists
i wonder why i wonder why is it that it
appeals so many to so many lgbt
q i'm not sure i don't know it's hard
just hard to say
but i think they're because it's pop
music they're music's biggs in the
in the in the gay clubs and stuff and um
and all these artists are very very
progressive and very um
open and welcoming right well
i think it's nice that pewdiepie listens
to that music
yeah congrat good for him
and uh good for you ian as well
do you regret do you ever think about
that guy i mean were you tempted at all
or was like nah
just out of curiosity i mean it's like
him in the in the guy at the arby's
drive through
i'm uh oh yeah yeah you get love in the
most unusual places
but even like even if if i was into it i
wouldn't want to [ __ ]
that's not the right thing it's not for
you
well he said him he wouldn't he has a
message i wonder if a really hot
if a really hot girl came up to you and
was like hey
let's go in the stall have any of you
ever had specs in a public place
not sex not like full-on sex
not not in a stall not penetrated
nothing like that zack has zack has
zach's quiet no comments well how are we
defining public
uh not anywhere but i'm gonna private
place yeah well then
yeah i mean i have to well what do you
what do you mean by that like
an r you [ __ ] in a bar no car
car is different yeah your car is kind
of private
but it wasn't like in my driveway it was
it was in a public place
oh you've never done that but fair
enough i mean that if i [ __ ] in
i think it's not the same no it's not
the same that's the wild hurricane i
think we're talking about like a
restaurant
wait i just i have a memory of my mom we
kind of did it in a public place once
like a long time ago
just had a memory remember when we saw
the beatles cover band
it was so long ago but
what did we do oh we went into the
bathroom
well
that was a great show that was when i
first i like i just moved to israel
and um well here comes the sun i guess
yeah a little we went in the bathroom
and did something like we did something
there was foals yeah the home base
little little sergeant pepper we were
really drunk and
i think normally would have been really
gross but we were like too drunk
i guess i think that's why you have sex
in public yeah
but no it wasn't really public i mean
there was the door was closed and it was
locked no but it was a public yeah but
that guy threw him in a bar
yeah ian what zach what's your story
go ahead um i mean obviously car i mean
on a car yeah i guess we're determining
that that doesn't count
card isn't common enough
was it like a camping scenario was it
like a people were hiking
like were you in a tent uh it was at
night
um and it was just kind of like yeah
let's go do this
just like on the earth you guys just
boned on the earth [ __ ]
barbaric ape style
all in dude it's pretty that's pretty
epic you know i actually
i remember now i had totally forgotten
about this but in high school
in one of the practice rooms of uh
of the uh the band the music department
or whatever
so i guess that i mean at school that's
definitely wait you [ __ ]
in high school and band yeah wow so
people always talk [ __ ] about the bad
kids being uncool but they're actually
[ __ ] in the back room
pretty crazy always [ __ ] dude no yeah
the band is horny as hell dude
that's you're like coming to the band
i'll show you my trombone baby
and i play trombone so there you go yeah
you did so there you go the trombone
kids are getting you
right boys dan did you usually like
flute did you like do anything with the
flute like it's a toy
wait you did you have a condom for me at
that situation
uh no my girlfriend at the time was on
the pill
oh wow that dude you guys were way ahead
of me yeah why
holy [ __ ] i don't even think i i didn't
have a girlfriend who was on the pill
until i was like 22 or 23.
oh really no no my my girlfriend in
college was on the pill
so you were less than 21. okay so it's
not that
i guess it wasn't not that far off yeah
this would have been because
i was how does that make sense because i
maybe my years are all mixed up because
i went to college when i was 18
and then i must have dated her like my
freshman
soph junior year and then you
came right when i was getting out of
college right
the numbers don't make sense because
that was like five oh you did an extra
year now
yeah that's five [ __ ] years so that
would mean if i went when i was 18
that i would have been 23 when you came
which makes sense i think oh
i think yes yes because you were 21 when
we met
[Music]
time passed and i never tapped that
until i was 23. clap those
geeks anyways this uh
was supposed to is playing the trombone
yeah that's pretty bad news for
everybody no i think i knew that but
i just think it's interesting that
mentions a marching band
kid can we get a trombone solo
i do still own a trombone but yeah
yeah bring it bring i mean i haven't
played in like a decade
it's just no expedia by the way
microsoft phone
so i'm not doing that you don't want to
get in the band again
but i do find it interesting that the um
but yeah i don't i haven't played the
horn in a long time dan and i yet to
have a jam sesh we need to do
trombone in a guitar no no like
two guitars or guitar and bass or
something
i'd watch that yeah as well
i'm not a shredder like zach but uh but
i can play
ian are you a musical at all i played
the drums when i was a kid
you did so we could start a band here oh
right ethan plays guitar too right yes
like
i played a lot better so i could be our
bass player you look at this we gotta
make another
jokes album call me out you could sing
and cannot sing
drum boom kids get [ __ ] i have
zero musical trombone kids can [ __ ]
all the cool kids are virgin stills but
trombone
kids getting [ __ ] trombone kids
getting [ __ ]
up little wings
there is that wings yeah that is wings
okay
i was cool but i was virgin but the
trombone kids getting [ __ ]
i thought band was so uncool
but the trombone is getting [ __ ]
i just shot my nut i couldn't shine
without i regret bringing this up
i got kicked out of uh zoom so i can't
cut to
zach and ian so we should probably just
guys it's been a pleasure it's been a
blast we will see you
tomorrow with chad njt the legendary
party bros
until then party on i'm garth and you're
bro wayne peace guys see you tomorrow
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you